ah non je les ai vus j'ai vu le dos
[Musique]
l'invitée exceptionnelle
il a souhaité venir dans notre émission
ce soir je vous le dis il sera là dans
un instant mais il va falloir trouver
quels invités y est avec nous ce soir
jean michel vous avez essayé de trouver
le premier indice après bien sûr endroit
là la chronique de berck rocha notre
première à 10 pour notre invité du jour
qui est l'invité ce soir ne touche pas à
mon poste
personne ne le sait ici le premier
indice essayer de trouver chez vous
également demain au cinéma demain au
cinéma ou là demain au cinéma
allez-y bah tu sais plus trop les uns
structure dans le 3 c'est très sympa
soit le 3 est bien plus sympa non
mathieu aller si c'est le deuxième
simple c'est le deuxième avis pour
savoir qui est notre invité ce soir vous
jouez avec nous chez vous c'est pas ça
penche toujours juste dans ses passes et
repro
allez-y c'est bon vous l'avez ou pas
vous l'avez voilà certes et je n'ai pas
la halle et ben ali qui l'a pas là il
alla alors qu'il n'arrête pas les voilà
attention deuxième à 10 lisez le 2 0 à
10 de son vrai nom my own on my mind
bataille merci merci ah non je les ai
vus j'ai vu le dossier vous
mamie cran pour plus de 20 noms mais il
ya trois dinosaures dans les rues là bas
je fais pas su aidera à les y bouge
alors mais il est mort ou alors on vous
rappelle pour toujours à la merci merci
[Musique]
au sabbat voilà du barbu troisième
indice barbie ça les côtes
regardez la mère et la fille kara
[Applaudissements]
élagueur élagueurs le quatrième liste
pour la vita j'ai trouvé allez on y va
billy houle indices pour l'inviter
millet doit aller si yahoo lundi n'est
pas dans dix ans mais s'il est là bas
mais où est la non pas là je dois ouais
moi le truc vous aider merci merci s'il
vous serez tout seul je sais [ __ ] mais
bougez vous c'est bon c'est bon c'est
rouler ailleurs gelé mois alors
attention qui l'a gardé
qui c'est qui est l'invité de ce soir
est l'élagage énormément est ce que tu
es le chanteur préféré de cyril
ça qu on connait la voit s'éroder bateau
[Rires]
est-ce que c'est kenji oguro si c'est
lui qui était là était la gamme tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]